it is described as the largest financial
crime in Iraq's history an estimated 2.5
billion dollars stolen from the finance
ministry
investigators say government insiders
colluded with a state-owned bank and
five private companies cashing hundreds
of illegal checks since September last
year the fact that this continues for a
year without being uncovered without
anybody sort of being held to account at
the time shows that the people involved
have number one political backing and
number two that the collusion occurs at
the highest level I think the new
government has to establish its
credibility in one of these ways is
going to try to do to run public support
is to go off to corruption it comes at a
sensitive time for the new prime
minister Muhammad al-sudani took office
less than a week ago he's promised the
case as a priority and the Looting of
public funds will no longer go unchecked
but Iraqis say this likely represents a
small fraction of what has gone on for
years despite the fact that this Scandal
is so big no one here really seems that
surprised by it and that's because this
kind of high stakes high level Financial
corruption in Iraq Is An Open Secret
one of the largest oil producing
countries remains home to some of the
world's poorest communities
in baghdad's most densely populated
neighborhood Iraqis say corrupt
politicians may have survived Wars and
protests but their leader muktada
al-sader is setting the stage for
justice
his political block is no longer in
Parliament but his street power remains
intact
fueled by public anger
there is no future whether you are
educated or not young people have no
ambition we all have empty Pockets I
want to get married but I don't have the
ability if I get married and have
children how will I take care of them
and raise them
Iraq's working class say the elite lined
their own pockets and only Southern
cares about the poor his supporters were
among the first to join protests in the
past and say it is not if but when they
march on the government again
foreign